don't you fool searching I was not about  honey when we started as well in fact I  was on the other side of the law  [Music]  when I was in prison when my early 20s  in the 70s  my job was wardens barber the barbershop  was outside the prison gate so one of my  friends another inmate escaped the  rifles from the prison towers we on his  back and I didn't want him to kill him  and so as I tackled him a lieutenant ran  up behind me through these handcuffs  down on the ground and said hook him up  bounty hunter I got out of prison 1970  back February the six coming up is 40  years I said to myself in the mirror I  am gonna change it be the best at  whatever I do in the world and I started  looking at stuff what to do and all of a  sudden I saw bounty hunter made this  terrible mistake  like after 8,000 fugitive that I've  arrested I think I've redeemed myself  that I really like no I didn't dream of  being a bounty hunter I just dreamed of  being with the bounty hunter  [Music]